all right let's go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back once again
to your
absolutely
favorite podcast
wow
what's up everybody episode 151 back at
it riffing with griffin once again i'm
by myself so that's why i'm not sitting
in my normal place but i don't know
maybe i'm trying to rebrand you never
know what's going on with me but today
i'm going to talk about uh
upcoming shows last weekend shows new
podcasts i got coming out
i want to go into finally i want to talk
about big brother
i love big brother if you guys follow me
you know that and i want to review this
great netflix series i saw called click
bait so stick around for that
[Music]
[Music]
all right there we go and we did it and
we're back at it we're from with griffin
once again i'm by myself wigs is out of
town uh or i'd have him here with me and
i'd be sitting over there and he'd be
doing all this stuff but i thought to
myself you know what i need to sit at
the desk so i can like do all the little
like you know
show you the websites and put up the
little graphics up right
sorry i'm drinking coffee at the same
time uh thanks to everybody that's
listening
uh on all the audio platforms thank you
very much for being loyal listeners and
all you guys watching on youtube thank
you guys too
all right so um before i do uh even go
in about that uh next uh in a couple
weeks september
23rd to the 25th i will be at laughs
boston everybody laughs boston so come
check me out there laughs boston you can
go to their website you go to my website
i got a link there ticket link
on my crazy website but laugh boston if
you still you know come check me out
there go to laughs boston there and then
when you go to their website uh you will
see
you know
the ticket link for all the all the
different shows i got going on oh look
at that
for you people looking at me at on
youtube
but anyways
laughs boston uh that's that news that's
going on there
um let's see what else i got going on
um
uh also i got a movie coming out too uh
that's uh
kind of exciting i did this other um i
did this other movie uh called uh what
was it called um
electric love that was the name of it
same creators
too great just
victoria and they're just
you know they're just awesome um
they're they're awesome people man they
put me they've put me in the they're
they're two movies that they've made you
know what i mean the two movies that
they've made
and um
and i really appreciate they they do you
know every time they call me up i don't
even like look at the script i just go
i just go yeah you know i'll do it
let let's go you know what i mean
so you know that's that's when you like
really trust people so they're you know
they're really they're really cool cool
peeps
you know um aaron
i want to get his last name right
franken and victoria fratz and they're
actually actually a couple they're
actually engaged too but they're
actually a great like power couple
because they work well together and we
did this other movie you could which you
can see this other movie on hulu is
called electric love
uh let me let me go to electric gloves
so you guys can now here it is was that
in 2018 wow i can't even believe that it
was that long ago
yeah man electric love
uh it was like a
it's this great movie about
just like a little love story about like
a sort of modern love story about how
people are meet how people meet on the
internet and they have their own stories
and it's like a you know it follows like
two or three people's different stories
but it's like it's actually nice you
know mia sarafino a friend of mine now
she's great in it and
and um zach morin maurin i don't know if
i'm saying his name right but he was
actually he's in this other movie val
with me so he's a star val along with
this other chick misha and anyways you
know so check that out if you want to
see a funny movie like go check out
electric love
uh it's actually a sweet little movie
and then i got this horror movie val
which is coming out
you know
so check out val too all right
and then other news in my uh little
world again i've already talked about it
but i want to talk about it again make
sure you guys also check out my new
podcast on september 15th
which is in a couple days september 15th
this is gonna be this wednesday
make sure you check out
um gen de gen
gender gen podcast with me and my buddy
matthew espinoza who's like he's like 24
i'm like you know
whatever how old i am you guys don't
need to know i'm old i'm 49 and you know
we're just talking about the different
we're just two generations coming
together learning from each other about
what's going on this generation what was
going on in the past generation and just
coming from two different sort of
perspectives
old and young
uh you know common sense and then like
you know you know what i mean you guys
though you'll get it you get the concept
so if you want to check that out that's
going to be this wednesday so make sure
you uh
you listen to that and look at that on
all podcast
platforms
all right so this past weekend i was in
denver i was at the comedy works and
shout out to them it was actually a
great i had a really great time comedy
works was uh actually a really fun club
i i've been to the other one they have a
newer club it's actually a bigger club
out in like a different part of denver
but this is like the the original one
right right smack in downtown you know i
think the world's coming back slowly in
terms of my world the comedian world
it's coming back real slow man
i don't know if people are actually
and then it's like also with the rules
like people don't know what they want to
do yet i mean because there are people
who are don't want to get vaccinated or
haven't gotten vaccinated yet and it's
the kind of thing where it's like the
clubs i feel like they're going to this
like you know they're really worried
about their liability they're really
worried about like they just want to be
open and not have to worry about this
don't have to worry about
closing because their staff gets sick i
mean i get both perspectives you know
so they're all like you have to now be
vaccinated to get into the club so that
cuts out you know a portion of the the
population that doesn't want to go i
mean but listen you know when you're at
a comedy club you're literally sitting
right on top of people there's like
they're just like there's so many people
jam-packed into one room you know so it
is one of those things man we just got
to go how can we make this as safe as
possible uh you know how can we keep the
money flow coming in without having to
worry about shutting down and all that
kind of stuff so you know that is what
it is so i think and then also like uh
the mc would make ask like is this who's
this who is their first comedy show back
since the pandemic kind of thing and a
lot of times it was like it was like big
you know big clap so it was like this is
people's first time actually coming back
to the club because they just recently
opened up so
uh it was fun though
i had a fun time in denver denver's like
not too woke but like a little you know
those kind of finger snappy type people
i can't stand that [ __ ] by the way you
know just laugh you know what i mean if
you say something poignant or you say
something with some some common sense
approach i don't need your freaking
finger you know that clicking on your
finger snapping your fingers just just
clap just laugh just laugh you know what
i mean
some people that think they're smarter
than they really are when they when they
click their fingers they're when they oh
that oh yeah that was so woke you know
whatever it is i hate that uh but
they're they're like not there yet but
sometimes they're almost there my
favorite thing is to like make jokes
about stuff
and
that's kind of like an edgy subject but
i try to do it in such a fun way that
i'm still making woke people laugh
and i know when i'm making them laugh
and they don't want to laugh but they
have to laugh because it's funny and
then they're sort of covering their
mouth and they're kind of hiding like oh
my god i can't believe i'm laughing at
this i love that reaction i see a lot of
that i actually get a lot of that i mean
i have these i have these jokes about a
story about where i had a deaf guy
helped me
at the apple store and i just have a
whole feelings about it and i'm talking
about it in such a way that
you know what i'm saying you get me
you know what i mean and so you're going
to laugh
at but you're
this kind of nonsense wokeness that you
feel like oh well you're not supposed to
laugh about this you're warring with
that i think that is
that's my recent goal is to make people
war with themselves
you know and so it's like yeah you know
it's okay to laugh at anything actually
i mean the comics job is to like
my job is to like present the subject in
a way that you go
you you just have to laugh you know what
i mean i don't care what it is somebody
in a wheelchair it could be about
anybody it could be about anything
anybody and i'm the kind of person i
will do the jokes in front of who if i'm
talking about whatever type of person if
they're in the crowd believe me i'm
still talking about that you know i
don't care because i feel like i i feel
like what i'm saying is fair i'm not
punching down
i'm saying what i feel is fair and
common sense approach to it you know and
i'm trying to make that funny it's not
easy you know it's i've put myself in a
weird lane and it's sometimes it's like
it's challenging you know and it doesn't
always
again it doesn't always work and it's
fair for you to have whatever response
you have you know when you go to a
comedy show or you hear a joke it's you
know what if you don't feel like it's
funny that is a fair response but what
i'm saying is like what you do with that
response is what the problem with
society is right now i feel like you
don't like what someone's saying then
just don't like it and move on with your
life but people go oh i can't just not
like it i have to now
tear this person down and remove them
from society that is the fair thing that
that what they think is now fair so
that's what you know you become the
problem you know it's like at a comedy
show you as a comic you think
this is what it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be you don't find this funny
so you don't laugh
you know what i mean like
and then you move on with your life
now it's like you don't find it funny so
now you got to go home and tweet oh man
i was at this comedy show and this
person said this and then you put in
your own spin and take on it and then it
turns into like something that it's not
you know just just don't laugh you know
that's all you got to do you're done
your response to what i said that you
didn't like you have the most perfect
response
non-laughter just look at me with
indifference and then you will move on
to the next one and maybe you'll like
the next one you know
but
who knows
so denver was fun
now they hadn't they had a condo though
and like they hadn't been using the
condo i guess
you know they used a condo for the
comics but they haven't really been
using it so and they so there was a
little
like there was no
can you imagine
yeah i don't even know y'all don't even
realize as a comic when you don't have
internet at the hotel even any place you
go there's no internet like are you
kidding me like i don't know how people
did it before i don't know how comics
went to a place for a weekend and they
didn't have internet like this it's like
i'm so modernized in terms of just that
little tidbit
because for me too it's like game stream
and by the way you can check me out
daily on eric griffin gaming you know
check out eric griffin gaming uh on uh
on
twitch make sure you come check me out
i gain most every days i'll probably be
gaming after i finish uh doing uh this
podcast so make sure you guys come check
me out you can also see my uh videos
you can also see my videos of some of
the game you know like earlier game
streams
on um
on youtube where you can go to eric
griffin gaming there too so for the for
the people watching i'll show you you
know yeah here we go eric griffin gay
man and uh i partnered up with a gaming
chair company but you know you can see
all that information right there so yeah
so i have like all my videos and stuff
there so you can come check me out so
anyways the reason why i bring this up
is
when i'm on the road
i
um
i game i have to stream so i need the
internet to work you know
it's like i need the internet to work
when i get so like
damn internet wasn't working
and then and then they also had the
nerve to not having the tv no cable
hooked up or nothing but i actually
don't have necessarily a problem with
that it's because when i go
on the road i i don't even turn the
hotel tv on and there's plenty of tv
there i'm always looking at tv on my on
my uh
uh ipad now because i have
i have like everything like i spend you
know it's like before we spend all this
money on cable and we got these channels
and everybody's like oh we got to get
rid of cable because i have whatever but
damn i spend a lot of money on streaming
services guys i have first of all i have
youtube tv
highly recommend youtube tv man actually
and this ain't this ain't even a they
just it's so great
those streaming live tv services
maybe they're all good i'm just telling
you my experience with the one i have i
have youtube tv and you can have like
five people on your account um and you
get like local tv and i got it too
because you have the nfl red zone and
then you know you can it's just great
and it's like you can watch it anywhere
too like i'm looking you can look at tv
anywhere on your phone on your whatever
so i always i'm always looking at that
there but i got all these services so i
got youtube tv now
i got the new one the paramount plus
i just got that i got hulu i got netflix
i have amazon i have
disney who who with the hulu i have
disney and espn
uh did i say amazon yeah amazon it's
like and then at one point i had dc
universe
so i actually count hbo as a streaming
service now too even though that comes
you know you that's bundled even those
things count as streaming services when
they're bundled in with your cable or
whatever it is right so if you're paying
for extra premium channels
those premium channels are now streaming
services because like if you have
showtime you have show time anytime if
you have hbo max that's you know you can
stream that if you have you know so
these are all streaming services so i'm
like i'm just waiting for a company to
come together and be like hey get all of
that under one thing and that's just
going to be what we had before anyway so
now i'm you know i'm paying for seven
different streaming services you know
it's craziness and some of them all have
the same stuff on it so i don't know i
feel like i'm spending just an amount of
money on all this as i did when i just
had cable
and you feel like you're saving money
but you know it's like wait a minute i'm
spending still spending 150 180 dollars
a month for entertainment but you know
what though
as someone in the entertainment business
people should pay for it so i don't
really have a problem with it because
i'm like i get it
you know
it's just like um
you know for the longest time
i
like when you think about software like
think about like microsoft word
i i would imagine
for the last like 15 years or however
long microsoft word has been available
i always had a crack copy of it
you know i always had a bootleg copy of
microsoft word i don't know about you
guys but i don't think i've ever paid
for microsoft word uh or even photoshop
i got a computer sitting on my desk
right now i have a second imac that an
older imac right and it's sitting right
there
and the only reason why i have it is
because i have a copy of photoshop an
old-school copy of photoshop on it that
i still use to edit photos with because
photoshop is great
and i got and i never paid for that
photoshop and so
i have so many softwares like that so
then now i think the software companies
have figured it out where like you can't
actually buy software anymore you have
to like get a subscription to the
software now so it'll be like you know
six dollars a month for a photoshop or
however much they're charging for it now
it's all subscription service so finally
i was like you know what i've gotten
microsoft word for free for so long
it's time for me to start paying these
people for this thing that they provided
so now i like i got the the microsoft i
guess you have to sign up for this
microsoft thing and then you get you
know you get word and excel and all this
stuff i don't even know if the kids out
there even use excel anymore
but you could hear me sipping my coffee
but it is what it is so i'm finally
paying for that so
anyway
what am i trying to say one point is
it's the same thing with entertainment
you know it's like you know we get
you know it's like pay for it i mean it
goes it takes a lot to
um put together television shows and all
these things and it's like you know what
you know that we're in a capitalist
system people should you know be
compensated for what they do
you know i mean tv works actually tvs
works just like podcasting if you think
about it you get it for free like you're
getting this for free right now
uh me particularly but
but maybe not even like you might be
paying for some you know
you may be paying extra for apple music
and then you're getting podcasts along
with that even though i don't see no
money from that or like whatever how
whatever you're using to like get your
you know whatever you're using to stream
your stuff you're paying for that in
other ways but you we always forget
about the artist i mean that's the crazy
thing we always forget about the artist
you know like like it's like spotify and
all this stuff we pay for that and
recently now they've figured a way to
monetize and people get people are
getting some money but it's not big
money but it's like the artist the thing
you're actually using this for
uh that person gets screwed over the
most and these companies have all this
money
you know it's like you're you're
we we love the use of something like
spotify or facebook or whatever we love
the use of that
but we forget that we're using it
because we want to see such and such
we want to see this thing and that thing
that you want to see
that person gets the least amount of the
money some of the times so that's what
this is
and by the way just you know i love just
going on a tangent on my own podcast
because you know it's like i see both
sides too like say something like
facebook you know
so a lot of people are talking about how
like you can't
like they're not they're capping it they
don't let you reach all your followers
they don't you know all they don't you
know so you can't go viral as much as
people did before because they're saying
hey if you want to reach all your
followers hey pay me this amount of
money uh you know
when you like promote ads and you
promote uh posts and things on your
facebook when you promote those posts
when you pay those posts then they're
saying hey pay this and then we'll make
sure more of the people that follow you
see it now there's a side of that that
people are like hey these people are
following me i should be able to put up
a post and all my followers should see
it and i i understand that you know i
ultimately agree with that too but
i also understand the idea that hey
i'm a company
all right if i'm facebook i'm like hey
i'm a company i i provide the server
space
i have provided this service for you
pay for it
and i understand that too
like myspace instagram all the the same
company they've collected they've
collected and they've built a thing
where
millions of people like literally
hundreds of millions of people
are on instagram
and they're saying
hey we have to pay for this we have to
you know do the server space we have to
make sure you know we we we're the ones
that are making sure everything runs
smoothly so all these hundreds of
millions of people can be in one place
and you want to just say
and you and we're letting you
promote to all of these people that
service costs should cost some money so
they can keep the lights on and whatever
so
part of me understands it
but then there's other side where you go
well yeah but you're also you've also
created this thing where you're now
putting up ads to hundreds of millions
of people all at once and so i think
that's how you should make your money
and let us interact for free so it's
like two sides of that coin so i don't
know where you stand on that you know
i'm sure you can let me know in the
comments right there you know if do you
understand both sides or you know what
your perspective is on that uh just but
just try to be
try to be respectful man
you know what i mean you can have we all
can have our own opinion you don't have
to trash someone else immediately when
it's time to give your opinion you're an
idiot and then booboo will write
yourself you don't have to say all that
i'm open to all your sides just just
write what you think you don't have to
comment on what i think just write what
you think okay
all right
so here we go guys uh to uh now i
haven't talked about this in a while and
and i haven't talked about
um
i haven't talked about these kinds of
shows in a while because i haven't
really been watching them but i have
been watching this one you all know i
love big
brother
i love big brother i just i don't know
if you've never watched big brother just
to give you a quick recap it's usually
like let me see one two three four four
five seven eight nine
there's like 16 people they live in this
house they're completely locked in this
big house with a big backyard whatever
it is it's not even a house it's
probably like a studio but they have a
house it's completely insulated it's
like truman's show and they're being
recorded 24 7 even when they're sleeping
you can go to paramount if you have
that's another reason why i love having
paramount plus by the way because you
can get the big brother live feeds and
you can watch those as part of your
service i love that but anyways
they're being recorded 24 7 and it's a
competition show where these people do
they have these competitions against
each other and then they eliminate
people at every week someone gets
eliminated and it whittles down to the
last person and the last person wins 750
000 they raised they raised it up this
year
and they have these competitions and
they you know so you have to be like the
head of household when you win the head
of household competition then you
nominate uh two people for eviction and
then there's like a veto competition
that those two people have a chance to
like win some like physical competition
and then or some mental competition and
then they get to take themselves down
and then the head of household has to
nominate someone else and then then then
the whole group
uh
they
they get to like decide who gets to go
home so then then alliances form you
know so then people start to and that's
the whole point of the game i mean big
brother is a game of like it's a
psychological warfare it really is a
cycle it's like it brings out to me in
my opinion the worst in people it brings
out the worst qualities in people
and that's how you move ahead in the
game because you have to lie and and
cheat and you have to like uh you know
you have to lie to people's face i'm not
going to nominate you i support you and
then they go to the confession and
they're like i don't support her i just
told her what she wanted to hear i mean
that's what the game pretty much is and
so i think that's why people like
watching it because you just and then
and then it's like you know you want to
see somebody like well are they going to
play the game with integrity how do you
play the game in in with integrity when
750 000 is on the line and then like you
know you're making the right you have to
make choices for you it's a selfish
self-indulgent
really crazy game to watch and i don't
know that's why i love watching it so
i cut to this year so i've talked about
it in the past
uh you know
usually the show is it's just a bunch of
pretty people doing pretty things also
like pretty
they're pretty and they're athletic and
i totally get that actually i mean and
so let me talk about this first okay
because i've talked about this in the
past so big brother will have like
they'll have like you know in the past
it usually used to be
it would be
16 17
mostly white
mostly pretty they're they're all pretty
they're all athletic and i get why they
have to be athletic the athletic part
about it is all these competitions that
they have a majority of them
are physical competitions where they
have to like or endurance competitions
where they have to hold on to something
for like you know for like an hour
so like when you the head of household
competition will be like you have to
hold on to a thing and you're 10 feet
off the ground and you have to hold on
to this like rope and whoever lasts the
longest wins so the people that are on
the show got to be physical specimens
now the pretty part about it is having
handsome beautiful people is because
it's a tv show and people are at home
like you know you they're looking at
this and you know we love beauty okay we
admire beauty we admire that i mean it
is what it is and that's what you want
to see now in the past five six years
woke culture has come in and you know
these woke people think we want to see
ugly people on tv
you know oh
we have to represent everyone nah [ __ ]
no you don't like what are you talking
about if i want to see ugly people i
just go down to the to the post office
okay if i want to see ugly people i can
just walk outside all right i can just
look in them damn mirror and be like do
i want to see that that's why i'm always
like the seventh lead on the show i'm
the funny guy i know where i am and the
things i'm handsome to some people you
know what i mean but i'm talking about
just like pure
pure
walking down the street going damn look
at her look at him i know i don't got
that you got to get to know me and i
will charm the hell out of you look at
this beautiful woman i have that's going
to marry me okay so we all have that in
us but i'm just talking about raw
handsomeness beauty
that's what we want to see on tv
okay this is an escape from reality
i don't need to see
ugly [ __ ] on tv okay like stop
it's ridiculous okay so this woke thing
has come around where big brother has
been like okay you know what we need to
do we need to have all different body
types we need to have and they still
like they they'll have some homely
people on there let's just say that i'm
gonna say ugly i'm just saying they're
not exceptional okay they're just like
you see that go oh that's
that's a chick i know this chick type of
thing and i go okay that's fine you want
to do that that's fine uh but the one
that bugs me though what they do is they
have people who are not physical they
have people who are not athletic and
they have people who are not in shape
on the show
they always fail
they always fail and they and it's like
why are you doing this the one guy on
the show this this year
his name is derrick frazier actually the
son of uh uh uh frasier the the boxer
you know he's this
fun fat gay dude okay
and
he even says like damn i feel like the
fat kid at camp that can't do anything
yeah cause you are that's exactly who
you are he's the fat kid who can't do
any of the physical stuff that everyone
else is doing and it's like what it's
like to me
don't have him on the show
or you need to have
fat sort of activities so he can shine
you know what i mean because it's like
to me it's like ridiculous so you
putting him on the show and you setting
him up for failure just to appease these
woke [ __ ] out here in the in the
world these you know woke idiot these
social justice warrior idiots who think
are you happy now so now you have the
fat guy feeling like a fat guy
to appease your stupid white guilt or
even not you know what let me retract
that it ain't even just white people who
are like stupid woke okay it's all of us
all racism
of people who think they want to speak
for everyone you know it's like you're
so stupid so now you've got this fat
dude who can't freaking do any athletic
stuff and he's failing and he feels
terrible about himself just so you can
feel good at home being like well now
everyone is being represented shut up so
get this fat dude off this damn show and
get somebody in shape on here because
that's what the damn show is about it's
so stupid so anyways
that piss that pissed me off they pissed
me off with this now you know what i
mean they really pissed me off it's like
yes let's get people from all walks of
life you know you can have in shape
pretty asians you can have in shape
pretty latinos you can have in-shaped
pretty black people pretty white you
know what i'm saying but that's what we
want to see okay and that's what that's
get that on there and stop all this
other nonsense all right all right
that's my rant about that so
anyways
for
the history of the show
everybody this one has been white
are pretty much white okay like for a
majority of the people i think that one
chick won i don't think she was white
and she was like the football she was
like a she was like a female football
player uh i i felt like she was like not
samoan or but she was something like
that but no one black has ever won the
show okay
no one black has ever won the show so
now let's go to this year's cast of big
brother okay so here's the cast of big
brother and if you look at it there are
actually one two three four five six
black people in the cast this year
i don't know if there's been that many
before but maybe there has i'm not it
doesn't matter i'm just saying but as a
person of color myself i just like i saw
that and i was like oh this is great you
know
uh there was like a you know there was a
chubby girl
you know you got the asian guy
you know it's always like a bunch of
pretty white people and a couple of
mixed people that this it's just what
they do but there's six black people on
the show
now
day one now i told you on big brother
alliances are formed okay alliances are
formed and they always have a name for
their alliance and they're like so
secretly all these black people got
together
the six black people got together and
they said hey
let's have a secret alliance
let's have a secret alliance
to get all six of us
to the end of this show
where we will ensure that a black person
will win big brother
and they did it
they got together and they did it and
now and they are the six that are left
and this one chick tiffany
at the bottom the bottom left there
tiffany came up with a plan
she came up with a plan that said we all
need to
buddy up with another person in the show
as a duo
and then
it and make everybody feel like they're
this duo is like you know a strong duo
so then when they get nominated and they
they even said to themselves too let's
say they went ahead of household they
will nominate one of the cookout
plus their duo and then they have the
numbers to vote the other person out and
that's what they did all season and it
was
masterful plan and they executed it and
now for the first time ever in big
brother history there are six black
people that are the final six and a
black person will win the show unless
they come up with some nonsense for us
like oh
uh two the fight back the fight back and
here's two more people get to come into
the back into it but other than that
they did it
and they and it was tough they were
fighting each other
you know this one the girl tiffany down
there she
she's selfish but she it's a selfish
game
but this oh man so they had this thing
where
it was the final seven of them okay
and
it was supposed to be they were supposed
to let this one guy win or any other
person win except her and then because
her person was this white girl claire
top right
it was her and claire and so
they they did they did the competition
and tiffany was supposed to throw it and
she didn't so she won
the competition and then she put up
uh xavier
ball head black dude at the bottom there
she put up xavier and his duo person
elissa up at the top
but then what happened was xavier won
the veto took himself down now she
tiffany now was forced
to put her girl up
and it was dramatic but she got what she
deserved because she was being selfish
but to her credit
she
put that girl up she told her hey listen
i can't i don't want to be responsible
for sending someone of color home and i
have to put you up and it was so
dramatic and everything they were crying
and all that but she got what she
deserved she shouldn't have done that so
i'm pretty sure she's not gonna win
because of that now
now let me get like some you know big
brother i've watched big brother now for
the last like seven eight years now and
only one time i've seen like the a-type
male
um
you know athletic dude win
and that was the year and they called
the guy racist it was it was crazy but
anyways
of the people that are left
i don't know who's actually gonna win it
really is gonna depend on who who
positions themselves in the right way
and also oh by the way one of the things
i like about big brother is there's a
certain point when you get kicked out
you become part of the jury
and then you so you go from the big
brother house you get kicked off and now
you're a part of the jury and this jury
of like 10 i believe or seven or nine i
think it's a jury of nine
they get to decide who wins big brother
so the two people at the end are sitting
in chairs and they have to like ask then
the jury asks them questions so you know
when you turned on me so it's a lot of
bitter [ __ ] in the jury okay a lot of
times it's a lot of bitter people in the
jury and what ends up happening is
um the person that you think should win
doesn't win because you know and that's
what usually happens like for the past
like the game's broken like the person
that should win in my opinion hasn't
really won it's one one out of seven
times in the in the past seven years in
my opinion the person that should win
big brother doesn't win like it's all
you know who it is it's somebody who's
kind of like kind of like a a beta
they're just kind of there
they've won some competitions but
they're not ruffling any feathers
they're pretending like they're oh what
i didn't do anything you know they're
pretending to be like this like you know
and they and they don't deserve the
money in my opinion but maybe that's
part of the game play but who knows it's
just your
whatever you think what you what you
think who should win but
so of these people like like i said
let me put him back up on the screen so
there's the fat kid that's derrick
derrick frazier you know he you know
what i mean
he would in a normal situation i think
that if he ends up
at the end
if he ends up bad but see i don't even
know now because the cookout what they
did was so masterful and now again also
there's six of them okay so four of them
are gonna be in the jury okay so
it just depends on
who they want who they convince the
other people that are in the jury to
vote for like you know what i mean like
i feel like tiffany came up with the
master plan okay she came up with the
master plan to kick everybody out if she
ends up in the final two she should win
because she did the most
even though she was selfish and all the
things she did she did the most but if
she is in the final two she should win
period that's what i think she would be
the most deserving to win because she
was the most terrible uh she was the mo
but also the smartest it was the
smartest plan i've ever seen in big
brother history they executed it even
when they were in fighting so tiffany is
to me the person most deserving to win
big brother but will she win i don't
know like the chick aza up there uh
she didn't do anything she can't win any
competitions you know so it's like i
don't know if she's sitting next to
tiffany ozza don't deserve the money and
i think the people in the cookout would
know even if they don't like tiffany and
they don't like her because she made
some selfish choices they they gonna
pick her and the other people that are
in the jury are gonna be like wow she
came up with this plan i can't believe
it so that she would win um
now derek he has the
best chance to win too uh uh not derek
xavier uh ball ball head black guy in
the bottom there he was
he
he he's been a part of he was throwing
competitions winning them when he should
uh he went on the block and survived he
he made sure the cookout
moved forward and went so if he's
sitting so like if it's tiffany and
xavier sitting there i think xavier wins
it because everyone else don't like
tiffany okay so that's the thing too
i think and that's why it behooves
tiffany to make sure to kick xavier out
and save them in xavier if he
has a chance to kick her out he should
in this final time so you know but the
ones and then that kid uh kyland uh the
other like the curly head black kid this
dude right here he um
he's another one that like i think if
he's sitting next to tiffany or xavier
he doesn't win
because he hasn't done enough
to
you know to do it but who knows it just
you know depends on the jury so but the
ones but who might win this chick hannah
or aza those are the two kind of people
that kind of win big brother they're
just kind of like blah they're kind of
there they don't really do much but
they're sitting next to somebody that is
like hated
and then they they get the votes that's
what's happened so many times but you
know what we'll see
uh they're fighting it out this final
six so it's the last like five weeks of
the show about to happen and i just feel
like
you know we will see how
it comes about
you know i mean we'll see if but it's
actually very fascinating and i'm
curious just to see if like you know
like you know
people talk about race a lot i mean i i
like the thing i don't talk about race a
lot but i know i talk about race too i
don't make everything about race because
i don't like that i don't i think that
you know i don't care about your age
race gender sexual orientation i just
think that you could still be an [ __ ]
even with those things
and if you know and i hate that and so
and if i go you know you're being an
[ __ ] and then you're like oh no
you're you're only saying that because
i'm and you did you fill in the blank of
whatever you want it to be i i don't
like that we've set our society up where
that's what it is it's like anytime
somebody sucks they have to be they
can't just take the they can't just be
like you know what i could have sucked
right now maybe this isn't because of my
age race gender or sexual orientation
you know that that's a thing and i think
that that's what's wrong with what's
going on right now is now we can't
criticize anybody without them bringing
up their thing
and i hate that you know i hate that uh
but that being said i do wonder of all
the the big brother fans of all the are
you sitting at home now being like like
do you are are there white people out
there who are like damn i can't believe
those black people did that or
are you mad because it's all six black
people or do you notice it is it a big
deal to you uh are you like are you are
you do you admire it or you know are you
mad about it like you know because they
played the whole house man they played
everybody they played them to it like
like an instrument and here we are and
they did it so i don't know how you do
people have feelings about it i mean
it's weird i mean this is like the sign
of like how times have changed or you
know i don't know man it's just it's a
weird feeling i hate that we live in
such a society that race is such a thing
you know gender uh
sexual orientation uh you know all this
stuff it's like it just bogs down our
minds you know once we're able to
normalize all those things when when it
just doesn't matter anymore then we
could just get to like
you know who's the most talented who's
the smartest who's the funniest you know
who's the most qualified who's the most
skilled you know i wish we could get to
a world where those things mattered more
than
tribalism you know more than like well i
want to be around people that you know i
look like you know it's like we're all
victims of it you know because even
myself i'm looking at this and i love
this and i love it do i love it because
i love big brother and the best people
have been there or is there a part of me
that's like yeah good i'm glad it's all
black people finally i mean
is that a fair feeling to have too so i
don't know it's just something to think
about guys it's really something to uh
i don't know you know what i mean
i don't know i know there's people that
watch the show there's like i always get
you know these like you know like really
non-thinking uh comments some people
that just immediately jump to
you know
they're like oh you're you know you're
doing the same thing you know whatever
they're not they're not really hearing
me they don't wanna have a nuanced
discussion i'm gonna make some nuance to
merch you know if you if you out there
if you're a good artist you want to help
me with some nuanced merch
uh you know some riffing with griffin
nuance based merch hit me up about that
because uh i need some i need some new
merch
um anyways all right so that is my big
brother take
you know so i'm looking forward to
seeing how it all ends
all right so now
this is the point in the show well i'll
tell you right now spoiler alert spoiler
alert spoiler alert i'm giving spoiler
alerts right now
so if you don't want this show to be
spoiled and the next thing i'm going to
talk about right now is click bait it's
just show on netflix so this again is
the spoiler alert time in the show so if
you haven't watched clickbait uh you
thank you for listening to riffin with
griffin thank you for watching we're
from wick griffin and please come back
after you've watched clickbait but if
you
have watched it and you want to hear me
talk about it now is the time let's time
stamp it now okay i'll give you a second
thank you for watching
everyone else that is still here thank
you for being here let's talk about
clickbait man
clickbait was
oh man i don't even know what to say
about this show man uh zoe kazarin betty
gabriel phoenix uh these are some of the
stars of the show there's a dude from uh
from uh
entourage who i just i'm not a huge fan
of his acting i think that was always
the biggest problem with entourage is
like i never believed that he was a big
star
you know what i mean but you know he he
does what he does in this in this thing
so click bait man click clickbait
clickbait
clickbait is about
um
it's about
a guy
well actually
i mean it is what it is what it is what
it sounds like you know so click bait is
about like so this guy is
kidnapped and a um a video is put on the
internet and the video says like you
know i abuse women
uh you know and he has to hold up a sign
that says i abuse women and at five
million views
i will
be killed i'm gonna die at five million
views
so now it's about
this you you see the story unfold in
front of you
you know and it's about you know so you
find out about this guy you find out
about his family you find about about
his kids and and uh
you know the events that led up to
this
this him being kidnapped and ultimately
being killed by the way like i said i
already gave you the spoiler alert so if
you you know if you mad that you're
hearing stuff right now that's on you
okay i gave a huge spoiler alert all
right
at five million views i die that's what
it says
so
all right let me talk about the show
first
first of all to me this show
this show felt feels like an algorithm
show what do i mean by that
it feels
like netflix has a super computer that's
like what are all the things people like
to see
let's put all those things in the show
then they went to a creator and said
okay i need you to make sure that it's
like super diverse let's have a bunch of
mixed ra it has to be super diverse
and it has to be about murder and it has
to be about this and then you know they
said okay got you and then they put it
together because you had everything in
this show like everything okay you had
evil white men uh you had uh
female strong female leads you had
mixed race you know you had like a black
woman with a white guy and these mixed
kids the cop was middle eastern uh you
know what i mean it was like
it was i mean it was like a hodgepodge
of every everything you think if you
were woke you would have loved this show
okay and uh you know so that's what that
was about you know and so i thought that
from the looks of it i was like oh they
really you know they really
they really they really had a a mixture
of things in here uh that you could just
get lost in that and then forget about
that and then like it become just get
into the story but the story to me is
what really it was really great so you
come to find out
that so this guy's been kidnapped and
now they're you know he has a sister and
his sister's like sort of this like
really toxic
sort of alcoholic loud
white girl who just is like you know you
don't like her at first i don't know if
i ever liked her in the show so the
actress played they played her just
doing a great job and you know it starts
with a family fight you know and then
the brother's like get out of here i'm
sick of you
you know what i mean
the black wife obviously doesn't like
her you know i mean so it's like it's a
whole thing you know then this guy
disappears all right then the guy
disappears and then they're trying to
figure out what's going on what's going
on in his life then they come to find
out he has these online profiles he has
these online profiles where he's been
like
you know seeing other women you know
you know so he's like oh man
he he you know he's online on all these
different dating sites
and then you come to find out the wife
okay the wife has an affair
all right
so the wife has an affair and then you
flash to her telling him about the
affair
and then them thinking that
because he had she had an affair he got
on his dating profile and met up with a
woman and cheated on his wife so this
other white woman comes forward and
she's like yes i had a relationship with
your husband
and you know so now it's like oh wow
now they're starting to think
man
uh
you know i abuse women then another
video comes up and it's like you know i
killed a woman you know it says i killed
the woman and so now they're in there in
the uncovery of the investigation you
start to find out
he has a bunch of profiles with fake
names and he's talking to you and seeing
a lot of women you know he's seen a lot
of women and then and so now they're
figuring out they don't know who this
guy is and then he works at like a high
school like at a sports center with like
young women they're there and then
you're starting to get a sense that oh
man he was he had an argument with one
of the volleyball players and that woman
left the team and and so now you're
thinking oh man this guy's a complete
and total creep and you know now you
think maybe he should have died so now
the cops are kind of on that tip of like
you know he should have he should have
been killed you know he this he this
happened for a reason and then the story
unfolds you know you start to find out
like you know oh man uh uh the one woman
was lying you start to you find out that
the one woman she said she had an affair
with him you find out
actually she never really met him and
this was all actually a whole big
catfish thing and then you start to find
out oh he never made any of these
profiles and someone else made the
profiles and that's the person that you
end up ultimately killing him you know
and then you find out so then they have
all these red herrings where it's like
you think it's his partner that works at
the the center who turns out to actually
be a creep you know so you think is it
him
you know what i mean and then you find
out like oh then so then you find out oh
man one of the girls that he was dating
was super messed up in her head she was
like bipolar and like uh you know she
was super depressed and this online
relationship she was having with this
with him was like keeping her afloat and
then like there's these text messages
that you see where he's trying to break
up with her like look i can't see you
anymore i don't want to see you anymore
and she's like well you know i told you
what i'll do if you break up with me and
then the message is like well look do
what you got to do it's not you know
whatever and then that girl ultimately
ends up killing herself so she kills
herself and then her brother finds her
then you start to realize then you find
out the brother the brother and his
coworker
they are the ones that kidnapped him and
made the video and you're like oh man so
he actually did kill a woman because he
killed a woman with his actions and and
so but then it gets even more
complicated so then in the process of
finding this out and then investigating
and the sister goes and talks to the the
the brother of the dead girl and the
brother is like
he's like hey
i let him go actually i had the wrong
guy
you know he realized he made a mistake
so it turns out
he made a huge mistake it wasn't
it wasn't uh
because you find out that it never was
this guy at all um what's his name let
me get his name right um um what the
hell's his name
uh
adrian grenier adrian uh is his name you
know
uh you you come to find out he you know
he he
he didn't make any of these profiles
that someone was using his identity the
whole time
okay you come to find out he actually
didn't cheat on his wife at all he never
cheated on his wife uh he had a profile
from like a long time ago it felt like
maybe he was thinking about it maybe he
made the profile and then he just
stopped and he just wasn't doing it
anymore okay so all right oh man it just
gets good so
so then like the so then like the
brother reveals i let him go and then
you cut to now the cops think this the
case is closed because they got the
brother of the dead girl locked away
case is closed the sister's like no i
don't i believe this guy i think there's
someone else out there you know and then
like
the the sun
the sun like he's got some like you
think he's being catfished by some girl
by somebody
that's getting information about you
know where this
you know everybody's interested in this
murder because the guy dies and
everybody's interested it's like a
national
oh man this guy was you know taken
hostage and sort of the whole country's
talking about it so he's like been
talking to people so he's talking to
someone who and then now he's starting
to be suspicious like hey is this uh are
you are you real and then he goes and
meets up with her and she actually is
real she's helping him now figure out so
then the sun
they track down with the metadata on the
pictures and they figure out where
the pictures actually came from and you
know because it was all fake all the
profiles were fake you know the pictures
were being manipulated you know and then
you you know you come to you find out
like you know they find out oh the
pictures are at this certain house and
then the little brother is on his
computer he shouldn't be and he sees the
messages and then the little brother's
like he gets a baseball bat and he's
like i'm gonna go to that house and i'm
gonna beat up whoever killed my dad like
you know that stupid youth type of thing
you know so he goes over there
and when he gets to the house
he's at the house of
a woman that works with
his dad
and then you see flashbacks of
her meeting the dad
and she's like this sweet old lady who's
like you know middle-aged woman who's
like hey i'll help you with your
computer and she's the one that like she
sets up his computer and he's kind of
like oh yeah here's the passcode to my
phone and you know he's just like
whatever and she's like this sweet woman
and she like she has access to his phone
and access to his computer and all this
stuff you know and then you know when
when you flash back to when he's like
released by the the brother of the dead
girl you know he says i only told one
person about the affair and he knows who
it is and it's this middle-aged woman
right so this whole time you think you
think you know who the killer is you
think you know who did all this right
and it's so complicated so then like you
flash back now and you see adrian he he
gets to this old woman's house he's like
why did you do this to me i knew it was
you i only told you and then you know
he's like i'm going to the cops and he's
like i can't believe you did this and
then the husband of the old woman claps
him on the head with a with a hammer and
they actually kill him they they're the
ones that actually kill him this old
white woman and her husband kill him put
him in the woods and because look they
have an alibi because the kidnapper said
they were going to do this anyway right
but the metadata on the pictures
gets the the young son comes to the
house and now they're like oh [ __ ] we're
caught so they kidnapped a young kid
this little half mixed kid you know and
they take him off
to their little cabin or whatever and
now the chase is on you know and then
you see the flashbacks of what happened
it's this lonely woman her husband's not
giving her any attention and what she
did was she's catfishing all these women
she used the pictures of the guy and you
know she made all these profiles and
then she's talking to them she's like
living vicariously through this made-up
version of the guy and she she gets on
the phone and changes her voice because
the other son figures that out because
he talks to the chick who said she was
having an affair and she claims she met
up with him in real life she he goes did
you really meet up with my dad he gets
on a facetime call with her and he's
like did you really meet up with my dad
and you know i really need to know and
then he she finally reveals she says no
i never met up with him but it was so
real to me and that he plays a uh uh he
plays a voicemail of his father's voice
and he goes is this who you were talking
to and then now she's like oh no that
isn't who i was talking to now and i
don't know if you've ever been catfished
i've been catfished okay and that moment
where you realize you don't know who the
hell you're talking to is scary
so this woman that's how they got the
information too they reveal that
she goes i haven't met him and that's
when you realize no one has met anyone
like none of these women and things like
what you think you know you don't know
right and then they get so then you know
the cops converge you know they rescue
the kid and now you find out all this
stuff you know and it's just like the
way they put it together it's so great
if you watched it i know you loved it uh
but you know
so my ending thoughts about it is like
it's so crazy because you go it's like
what did they ultimately end up doing
you know because then it turns out like
whose fault was everything so after i
analyzed the show afterwards and i was
like wow like you're it's like a
mind-bell bending thing of all the
things you have to you think is
happening you think you know who the
killer is you think you know what's
happening you know then you just go damn
ultimately he was actually a good guy
good dad good husband ultimately his
wife cheated on him
his wife cheating on him
drove him to
drove him to like telling this woman who
ultimately went on this trail because oh
then this okay so remember the brother
of the girl who killed herself because
she thought she got broken up with by
the guy
they show that scene so the husband so
to the wife the oh the middle-aged woman
she's all hyped up now she's all like
she got sexual energy now pretending to
be this guy and being like in love with
these women and saying all this stuff so
now she get into the bedroom with her
old man husband and she's like i need a
little piece you need to give me some
now so they have like this like sex and
it was a great scene how they showed it
i thought it was very like you know it's
like you don't want to see your parents
have sex and this is what this scene was
but good for these actors for like you
know really playing it well you know but
then the husband
he finds her computer and he's like what
the hell is this who are all these
people you're talking to and now she's
like oh my god i'm sorry you know i just
it's not real and so he's confronting
her and they're having this argument and
he's like you need to end this now so
she's all hyped up and upset because
she's having this argument with her
husband so now she sits in front of the
computer and then the uh the um the girl
who is like a psycho the girl that's got
not gonna say psycho that's that's bad
she's got mental problems okay she's
she's going through some stuff
now that's when that argument happened
she's like where are you where are you
you're not are you ignoring me and then
and then the old woman now who was like
gonna lose her husband and she's like
she's all like look i'm not your
therapist i don't wanna talk to you
right now you gotta leave me alone and
then you know the girl's like i told you
what i'll do if you don't do this she's
kind of like i don't care do do what you
want to do it's all you know and that's
when the girl kills her that's what
triggered that
so you almost go
everything's justified is what i'm
saying and that's what made it
interesting you know it was no one's
real fault you know it's like
the wife has an affair
and she breaks it off and then
that you think it's that guy too because
you know the the the guy and then like
you know she you know she has an affair
with a she's a teacher so she has an
affair with someone at the school so
that her kids go to that school so that
that causes issues because now the
affair comes out and then people think
this guy is a monster that turns out the
husband like i said turns out the
husband was like great dude
the wife was the cheater
you know turns out so it's like
ultimately all
as woke as they tried to make this show
ultimately it was all the women that
that messed everything up
you know what i mean it was like this
black woman cheated on her white husband
and and triggered a chain of events and
then this middle-aged white woman
middle-aged white woman caused a death
and all this like you know it killed him
and all this kind of stuff so i don't
even know if they achieve what they were
trying to achieve ultimately in the in
the thing but it's completely worth the
watch i love the kind of show that makes
you think i love a kind of show that
like makes you think about even race
stuff if it makes you think about race
if it makes you think about life if it
makes you think about hey who like
who are you really talking to when
you're on the internet talking to people
even if you think you know the person or
even if you've met them that thing
you're saying that those words you're
saying it's not real man it's not real
and you got to be aware of that you got
to see people in person even if even a
voice can be fake you know
you're not that's not the person so it
really brought up all these themes and
talks and uh if you came if you went and
watched it and you came back and
listened to this portion of the podcast
i really appreciate that but for people
that didn't even care cause they're
never gonna watch it anyway i think you
still should go watch it because it's a
great watch and so i super super thumbs
up
super thumbs up for click bait on
netflix totally should watch that but
you know um
i don't know and if there's a if there's
a sh if there's a show out there that
you're like griff i want to see what you
think about this show and
you know you want you want me to take a
look at it i i for sure think you know
send me some [ __ ] in the comments and
i'll be sure to uh you know what i mean
i will listen you know what i mean so
but
ultimately
that's it this week uh thanks for
listening and watching uh riffing with
griffin uh you know we're here every
monday uh like i said i'm coming to
boston so make sure you people are
boston in like two weeks i'll be at the
laugh boston 23rd to the 25th so uh come
check
that out and um
you know make sure you check out jen the
gin podcast on september 15th
i'll be on king and sting some more too
so check that out it might even be a
permanent thing i think we haven't
decided yet so make sure you guys uh you
know look for me on there too that's a
fun podcast to be a part of and you know
keep coming here i'm still gonna do
ripping with griffin i got real world
advice from a grown ass man coming up
soon i i like doing them live i might
just switch to completely all live every
week i might i want to incorporate some
fan questions maybe live fan questions
who knows well i don't know if i should
do that live i don't trust you people
but you know
we'll see what it is but
anyways
thanks for being here thanks for
listening thanks for watching thanks for
the support i love all the supportive
comments and if you if i triggered
something in you you want to talk about
something put it in the comments i do
look at the comments and let's you know
keep the discussions going
keep the common sense going and you know
enjoy yourself y'all thanks a lot
i'll see you next week